SACHIT EGAN: Well, hello,
everyone, and welcome to Talks
at Google.
My name is Sach Egan.
And today I have the pleasure
of introducing Tom Vanderbilt--
reintroducing Tom.
He was here at Google
[? around ?] eight years ago.
Tom is an author and
journalist, and he's
a contributing editor of "Wired
UK," "Outside," and "Artforum."
His work encompasses a
broad range of subjects,
such as design, technology,
science, and culture.
And his work has been
featured in publications
such as "Slate," "Wired," the
"Financial Times," "Rolling
Stone," "New York
Times Magazine,"
and "Popular Science."
Tom is the author of
"Survival City, Adventures
Among the Ruins of
Atomic America,"
and the bestseller "Traffic,
Why We Drive the Way We Do
and What It Says
about Ourselves,"
and he was here at Google a few
years ago to chat about that.
His latest book is "You
May Also Like, Taste
in an Age of Endless
Choice," and we're
going to chat about that today.
So welcome, Tom.
TOM VANDERBILT:
Great to be here.
SACHIT EGAN: Thanks
for being here.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM VANDERBILT:
I'm just curious,
was anyone-- anyone remember
seeing me for "Traffic" here
or-- hands.
OK.
SACHIT EGAN: High turnover.
TOM VANDERBILT: So it
is like "Logan's Run."
Everyone gets kicked out.
SACHIT EGAN: Pretty much.
You got it.
TOM VANDERBILT: Just checking.
SACHIT EGAN: Yeah, very good.
Well, let's begin
with the obvious.
So traffic to now
this subject about
taste, about what we like,
why we like these things.
Where'd you come
across this topic?
Why did you choose to pursue it?
TOM VANDERBILT: I've
tried to come up
with an elegant narrative that
links traffic and this book.
I haven't really found one.
One thing that
interests me about some
of these algorithmic
recommendation systems,
for example, is that
they do often-- I
found that they were often
pointing me to things
that I may not have
discovered for myself, for all
their flaws.
And just for a rough
traffic analogy,
I would say, if you talk
to transportation planners,
a lot of people do not
optimize their daily commute.
Even though that they've been
doing it 10 years in a row,
they have not found
the most efficient way
to do that, hence ways
and other services
could sort of use math
and things to point people
into new information that
they didn't have before.
So that's sort of some
of the rough analogy.
There's different ways to
think about traffic as a system
and some of the big
data aspect of taste.
But the simpler story is one
day I was walking to school
and my daughter asked me
what my favorite color was.
And I said blue.
And I gave this answer so
quickly and so without thought
that it almost disturbed me.
Or I thought, well, you
know, is it actually blue?
Do I have a favorite color?
What does it mean to
have a favorite color?
If it really is blue, where
did that preference come from?
And that question, where
do preferences come from,
is sort of what animated me
throughout this whole thing.
But there's a lot of
complicated stories,
but I try to tell that
one as the immediate way
in, that sort of animating
logic behind everything.
SACHIT EGAN: OK.
Great.
So is the intent of the
book then to broadly
kind of dive into why we
like things that we do?
Where these likes come from?
What was the intent, I
guess, when you set out
to craft it into a book?
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah, the intent
was-- going back to college,
I had read some of the
sociology on this stuff.
Pierre Bourdieu, he
had a whole other take.
But what Pierre Bourdieu
didn't have-- he
did interviews with
people in France.
He had about 1,200
survey responses.
Questions like, who's
your favorite composer?
How do you cut your hair?
Things like this.
But since then, we're
obviously now dealing
with a lot bigger
data sets here,
and that part
really interests me.
Being immersed in this
world where we now
have access to many more things
that I ever thought possible.
As sort of a teenager, I would
have died to have Spotify.
It can't even be
imagined how difficult--
how narrow that bandwidth
of my acquiring music was.
SACHIT EGAN: Sure.
TOM VANDERBILT: So once
that huge door was opened,
and then you're faced with
this terrifying chasm of,
oh, what do I do with all this
stuff now that it's there?
Another thing that
started to dawn on me
was how much I was being exposed
to what other people thought
of things, other people's
opinion, Yelp, TripAdvisor,
Amazon, all these sites.
And if you started to
read between the lines
of these long
strings of reviews,
there were some pretty
interesting dynamics,
I thought, going
on there as well.
So it all kind of
just fused together.
And just longstanding--
as a former college
radio DJ, just remembering these
endless debates about music,
and what was good
and what was bad.
So it's all--
SACHIT EGAN: It's all in there.
TOM VANDERBILT: It's a big stew.
SACHIT EGAN: Yeah, OK.
Well, let's try to dive
into that a little bit.
You have a quote in there
that, all tastes, in essence,
are acquired tastes, instead
of, I guess, implicit tastes.
And we should really be
calling them acquired liking
or acquired likes.
Why is that?
TOM VANDERBILT:
Yeah, that's what
a researcher at Monell,
the nutrition institute,
said to me.
And the funny thing
about taste is that you
can never quite nail it down.
It's not fully a learned thing.
It's not fully
inherent or biological.
It's not fully subjective.
It's not fully objective.
But I felt like people use
that phrase acquired taste
to describe these
sort of rarefied
or somewhat hard to like things,
like whiskey or something.
But really, that process
is pretty much the same
for most things we
go through in life.
There are very few things
that you just instantly
like the very first time
with no foregrounding,
and those would be the
simplest tastes, sugar.
But everything else is
this acquired taste.
And even that phrase
is sort of funny,
because it hints-- so
you come to like whiskey,
you come to like coffee.
These things were immensely
unpleasant the first time.
You're acquiring this
taste, but you're not
going back to this original
taste you had of that.
The signal coming in from
your tongue is the same,
but somewhere your
brain has sort of
reshaped this whole consumption
experience into something else.
And whiskey or coffee hasn't
changed, you've changed.
And that's what fascinates me.
And you see that with art and
with all sorts of other things.
And it just, again, spoke to
this sort of-- the picture
was less fixed than
I had imagined.
But yeah, I really do think
all tastes are, to some extent,
acquired.
Liking is learning.
It's sort of a
cliche, but it applies
more broadly than I think we
sometimes give it credit to.
SACHIT EGAN: The way
you speak of taste now,
when you have whiskey
for the first time
and you recall it later, you're
recalling this experience.
It's been processed
by your brain.
Something you do
in the book a lot
is you talk about
evolutionary biology.
You talk about how
tastes may have
a root in evolutionary bio.
How is that?
Why is that?
TOM VANDERBILT:
Paul Rozin, who's
a food researcher-- he's been
called the Father of Disgust,
which is kind of a funny title
to have-- he says that disgust
linked to food is sort of this
primal-- the primal dislike,
and that it comes with its
own set of facial reactions.
The aversive gape, where if you
drink sour milk or something
that you're not expecting, your
body is preparing to vomit.
You sort of shrivel
up your nose.
Your mouth has a gape.
They've seen it in rats.
They've seen it in
all sorts of things.
So it kind of speaks to
another aspect of liking,
which it really is pre-verbal.
Before we ever had ways to
talk about why we liked what
we like, or rate things
with stars obviously,
we had these nonverbal
ways of communicating
to our neighbor what might be
a dangerous thing to consume.
Consume, in that regard,
being food really.
But I think some of
the basic impulses
almost carry over to
other forms of art.
So if you saw sort of a
disgusting photograph--
a photograph that you
thought was disgusting--
you might have triggered some
of that same aversiveness
and aversive reaction.
SACHIT EGAN: I see.
And you also say that
we're predisposed
to be more acutely aware of
our dislikes versus our likes.
So that sounded very curious.
Is there a basis for that?
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah.
Again-- and you can make
an evolutionary bio jargon.
The food you dislike.
What you like is what
didn't kill you yesterday.
The food that's familiar to me
is the food you're still eating
and you haven't suffered from.
So it sort of makes sense.
You go with what's right in
front of you, what's familiar.
But dislike is sort of forming
an instinctive early warning
system.
It's more important to be
aware of your dislikes,
from that point of
view, than your likes,
because that's the hazard.
Obviously, a dislike for a
song isn't going to kill you.
And likes and dislikes are funny
in another way in that likes
are really a social thing.
We bond over likes and
we advertise our likes.
We tend to broadcast our likes.
Unless you're Johnny Rotten
from the Sex Pistols scrawling
"I hate Pink Floyd"
on your T-shirt,
people generally don't go
around saying, oh, I hate this.
I hate that.
I mean, we all know
someone like that.
But dislikes tend
to be more private.
Interestingly, from a brain
point of view, the evidence,
it's a little weird about
where liking sits in relation
to disliking, and it might
just be on the same spectrum,
and sometimes blurred, and
sometimes hard to figure out.
And done interesting
fMRI studies
where-- of course, fMRI studies
are always incredibly blurry.
You can't draw too
much from them.
But areas involved-- and
you show people photographs
of people they do not like,
and some of the same brain
activation happens as in
expressions of romantic love.
So the old cliche,
"There's a thin line
between love and hate" may
actually not be that far off.
And as long as we're
getting this powerful signal
in the beginning, I think,
we may tilt either way.
But what might be more
important is that you have--
something moved you, and maybe
you need to figure out how that
was and--
SACHIT EGAN: I see.
So sort of related to this,
you talk about assimilation
and contrast.
When we're told by a
friend or by a Yelp review
that we're going to like
something, one of two things
can happen, either
assimilation or contrast.
I guess assimilation means you
might also adopt that like.
Contrast is you kind of
push back against that like.
And you say with food
it's more common to have
this assimilation.
Somebody likes it, you
kind of like it as well.
But with media,
such as films, it's
more that you might push back
against somebody else's like.
Why is that?
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah,
although I think on Yelp,
you could see a lot of
contrasts as they call it also.
I think it has to
be one of the most--
if you did a word cloud
of Yelp, expectation
must loom pretty large.
This place did not live
up to my expectation.
This place exceeded
my expectations.
I've come to the-- just from
a personal point of navigating
the world, I've come
to the point of view
that it's better to suffer from
permanent low expectations.
And this might be just
speaking as a New Yorker.
And this is an interesting
way we categorize the world.
And you can-- I forget what--
I think the phrase was,
protection for the good.
But categorizing the
world is incredibly
useful in this regard.
And we all do this.
If you go to an
airport, don't think
you're going to have
the meal of your life,
but if you categorize it as--
if you lower your expectation
set to airport
food, you suddenly
can have a much more
positive experience.
With film, film just
gets so much more
into kind of personal taste,
which is a much harder thing
to nail down.
And we've all had the experience
of recommending something
to someone, like this movie
is going to change your life.
Turns out not to
change their life.
What went wrong there?
It's just a far messier
process, I think.
SACHIT EGAN: OK.
So you think it has
roots in expectation?
TOM VANDERBILT:
Expectation is huge.
I can't put a percentage on
it, but a huge amount of-- we
go into something either
being framed and conditioned
on how we think we're
going to like it.
And there's a lot of great
experiments about-- Heston
Blumenthal and some
psychologists did a study
about, give people
frozen savory mousse,
they find it disgusting,
they can't stand it.
Excuse me, give them
salmon-flavored ice cream.
They find this disgusting.
A little disgust was evoked
during this experiment.
Give them frozen savory mousse.
Don't know what to
expect, but it sounds
like a better proposition.
Doesn't violate some notion
of what's good ice cream.
People love the
frozen savory mousse.
So same exact dish.
And we've seen this
kind of blind taste test
with the same exact product done
in all kinds of different ways.
And it's just all about
how you're framing it,
what you're expecting
out of that.
SACHIT EGAN: Got it.
Can you talk a little bit about
variety amnesia, what is it,
and how it affects us?
TOM VANDERBILT:
One of these kind
of phenomena studied
by psychologists--
there's a another thing called
diversification bias, which
I mentioned in the book that I
suffered from and still suffer
from.
Does anybody remember the
Kellogg's variety pack cereal
in the grocery store?
OK.
So they come in these
24 packs of all this,
Frosted Flakes, Sugar Pops.
So I would beg my parents
to get these things.
And a week would go by, I'd
blitz through the Frosted
Flakes, and you get
down to the bottom,
it's like your Totals
and your All Brans.
So the question was,
why didn't I just buy
a big box of Frosted Flakes?
Because I was--
people often think
they want more
variety in the moment
than they actually want in
some consumption interval
down the road.
And the variety
amnesia is when--
it's kind of almost the
reverse of that, where
you forget how much variety
you've had in your diet,
for example.
[INAUDIBLE] oh, we just
ate there last week
or something like that.
But the point is is that
we're often unaware of how
much our tastes are changing,
either retrospectively
or prospectively, where they've
been, where they're going.
We're sort of not
as-- I don't know
how to describe it-- not
as aware of that status
as we think we are, I think.
SACHIT EGAN: I see.
Let's dive in a little deeper
with diversification bias.
Two examples in the book.
One, you spoke with the
folks who make MREs.
These are Meals Ready to Eat,
which soldiers are given.
And something that I
found really surprising
is, you might expect that
these soldiers will tire less
quickly of the flavorful food.
They'll enjoy variety.
They'll enjoy flavors.
But they actually tire far
less quickly of the bland food.
It makes more sense for them
to have blander food, I guess.
Why is that?
TOM VANDERBILT: The
argument I was given
was that flavorful food sticks
out in your imagination.
And the more you
can remember it,
the more you can remember
actually having it,
and it's sort of
availability bias.
It looms larger.
Bland food, you
sort of immediately
forget the experience.
So then the next time the
consumption experience
rolls around, you're ready to
roll again, and less fatigue.
And this ties into
something else.
One of my favorite sort of
phenomena we experience,
which is called
sensory-specific satiety.
And this idea that so much
of our liking, I think,
is based on
anticipation or memory.
And so you go into a meal.
You're very excited to eat it.
You start to eat.
And the moment you start to eat
a certain entree, your reported
liking for that food
begins to go down,
and it kind of falls
off the hedonic cliff.
And the way you can boost
your hedonic appetite back up
is to switch foods.
So the theory is the body
has an internal thermostat,
regulating, and giving
you signals of when
it's time to switch something.
But they've done
great experiments
with even Smarties candy.
And if you eat only
green Smarties,
you begin to get tired
of the green Smarties.
Give people blue Smarties,
suddenly their liking
goes back up.
So just this kind of
new-- it's a reset
of your palate and
almost your brain,
I think, and you're primed
to want more all of a sudden.
SACHIT EGAN: Interesting.
So related to that, one way we
marketed this talk internally
is we posed questions
that kind of come up
in the book to Googlers
and kind of whet
their appetite to come here.
And one of those
questions was, why
do we crave monotony
at breakfast--
or maybe not crave it.
We sort of expect to eat
similar things for breakfast.
But at dinner, we want variety.
I can't have Chinese, I
had Chinese last night.
So why is that?
TOM VANDERBILT: I'm actually
not sure that's been answered.
But it's a question that was
asked to me by EP Koester,
a Dutch food researcher.
I guess there's certain
situational factors, right?
You wake up.
You need convenience.
You're not going to go
looking for adventurous foods,
preparing adventurous foods.
Maybe there's something
about the body
just not being primed for
novelty upon waking up.
There's a lot of things we don't
do in the morning, I guess,
that we do do at night.
But there's simple just
structural factors.
Whether there are other
things beyond that,
I'm not sure that we know.
SACHIT EGAN: OK, fair enough.
TOM VANDERBILT: But I feel
like it is a real phenomena,
that I've stayed at--
we've probably all stayed
at a hotel in a place like
China and they have the five
different breakfasts
out of different foods
from different countries.
I always just go for,
like, the pancakes.
I'm never getting the
congee or whatever.
SACHIT EGAN: I need my Cream of
Wheat here at the Google cafe
every morning, and
that's just how I roll.
But something you
just mentioned.
We begin to like something
less-- some things
less the more that we're
exposed to them, OK.
But you quote, "some things
we like less the more we're
having them, but
there's an implication
that sometimes we like
things more the more we're
exposed to them."
And so you were talking
about complexity, I think.
Something like a
Coca-Cola or a Dr Pepper
is complex, keeps
us coming back,
versus an orange
soda, which might
be pretty nice the
first time you have it,
but your brain sort of, I
guess, gets tired of it quicker,
because it's not as complex.
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah,
this was a theory
that Howard Moskowitz, a food
researcher, kind of gave to me.
And Coca-Cola, you can't figure
out what that flavor blend is.
It's a more complex thing.
Your memory tires
of it less quickly.
Orange soda's pleasurable,
but you know it's orange.
There's not much mystery
upon the fourth drink.
The first drink is about
the same as the fourth.
And I sort of may be
taking liberties here.
I've sort of stretched
that metaphor
in the book to talk about
something like pop music.
I think psychologists
talk about this U-shape
of liking between
complexity and simplicity.
And we all kind of have a
slightly different point
based on the personality,
but humans, in general,
kind of want to be in
the middle of that.
And you can look--
you can almost
read pop music as this
simple sugary orange soda
rush that tastes
great going down,
but maybe hear it
10 times in a row.
Something like jazz,
or a more atonal,
or some sort of
more complex music
might be sort of a Coca-Cola.
If you want to read it, it's
a little harder to figure out
what's going on.
Takes longer to
appreciate it, perhaps.
SACHIT EGAN: Sure.
If you don't mind
me asking a question
related to my own life.
After reading this
book, a friend
recommended some music
to me recently that I was
listening to this past week.
And really loved a couple of
the songs, and binged them,
listening to them maybe five
or six times on one car ride.
What I've noticed the past week
is whenever I'm walking out
of a building, going
to another building,
I have these songs just
going on in my head.
I'm walking kind
of to that pace.
It's almost as if my brain--
I wake up in the morning
and I have the song
going in my head.
My brain's almost
figuring them out.
And I noticed the next
time I play the song,
it doesn't have that
same, oh my god,
this song is amazing feeling.
Is that sort of what you were
describing with pop songs
getting older quicker to us?
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah, and
it's an interesting thing
about hearing music
multiple times.
Psychologists talk about
processing fluency.
And I think the easier
something is to read,
the more we enjoy
it, the theory goes.
And what we like is not
so much the thing itself,
is our ability to
process and understand
that thing right away.
So I think it's what happens
when you learn a language.
Some languages sound
a little bit dissonant
to the ear when you
first hear them.
People say, oh, that's
an ugly language.
And I think it's not
ugly, it's just--
the people who speak it
don't think it's ugly.
It's just that you've
not-- you don't speak it.
You don't know
what to listen for.
You're not fluent
in that language.
So as you begin to learn
it, you begin to like it.
And I think language works
like music in this way.
Rick Rubin even
used the word-- I
think he used the word fluency
talking about Nine Inch Nails.
Like, the first time he heard
this Nine Inch Nails record,
he didn't like it.
He felt like he was
hearing a new language.
He didn't know what the
reference points were.
And this is a sort
of appreciation 101,
but I think it's
often forgotten, some
of these dynamics.
SACHIT EGAN: OK.
It's fascinating stuff.
Can you talk briefly about taste
as a tool for class mobility?
This is something that I've
been reading about lately.
I think a lot of folks
are covering this.
This idea that taste
implies, not just
who we are, but in
terms of what we like,
but where we stand in society.
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah,
I think the high era
of that taste as social signal
is we've passed it, I think.
It's sort of like
1950s, perhaps,
in terms of culture with
all these sociologists
with theories of highbrow,
lowbrow, and middlebrow.
And what happened in the past
few decades, people talk about,
is a cultural
omnivorousness came out
in which it wasn't so much
important the thing you liked--
you couldn't discount
entire genres all at once,
like country music is
not equivalent to opera.
You had to sort of figure
out, within those genres, what
was happening.
What's interesting to me,
someone living in Brooklyn,
New York, circa 2016,
is that as incomes go up
among a certain class and people
are more similar, you have
to fight harder to achieve
that distinction that was once
possible when societies
were more-- let's say,
going back to feudal
aristocracy times,
you knew what the elite
taste was, you knew
what the peasant taste was.
But--
SACHIT EGAN: Sure.
TOM VANDERBILT:
--everyone in Brooklyn
is within a certain
bandwidth, let's say.
So hence, you see this
kind of extreme signaling
and distinction at places
like coffee shops, where
each week there seems to
be some new form of coffee
preparation being rolled
out that I haven't yet
learned about, so I feel
slightly not up to snuff.
And the things that were
once luxury goods have become
democratized, and things
that were once everyday goods
have become increasingly
subject to these almost a
connoisseurial sort of energy.
So I've spent time with a
denim maker in South Carolina,
and he talks about he
paid $30,000 for a sewing
machine that is obsolete.
It was obsolete
from the 1930s on.
He tracked it down
in Thailand on eBay.
The reason he bought this
is so he could make what's
called a chain stitch.
There's a little
thing on the bottom.
These pants actually
don't have it, I think.
But denim connoisseurs,
of which they are now,
will be able to spot this
from across the room.
So he paid all this money
to create this little thing
that only a few people will see.
A huge social value
for those people.
And there was a very
happy guy in Thailand
who thought he was stuck with
this kind of surplus that
was able to resell it
back to the United States
at quite a profit.
SACHIT EGAN: Oh, that's great.
Let's dive a little deeper.
This actually-- it
really fascinated me.
So what I want to do
is I want to reference
an article published
in "New York
Magazine," the Science of Us
section, just this past week.
The article was
called "Why You Swipe
Left When Someone Says
They Love Nickelback,"
and it's by Cari Romm.
So she kind of parallels a lot
of the stuff you just talked
about, that late 1800s,
we have people moving
into more metropolis
areas, into bigger
cities, whereas previously,
courtship was old-fashioned.
And a gentleman would go
meet a woman's family,
spend time, and talk about
shared values, et cetera.
Now you have young people
in these big cities,
and the question is,
how are you going
to ever know who this person
hitting on you at the bar,
how do you know who they are?
How do you know what they're
about, what their values are,
et cetera?
And likes become this way
of connecting with people.
If you both like Nickelback or
if you both hate Nickelback,
you might bond
over these things.
But you mentioned that--
you cite the low success
rate of online
dating, which is often
based on just shared likes.
Do you think that-- I don't
know if-- you didn't research
heavily into online dating, but
do you think likes matter maybe
as much as we-- we put a lot of
emphasis on likes these days.
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah, I was
going to do some dating stuff,
and then I had lunch with
Christian Rudder who's
the OkCupid guy, and he was
working on his own book.
So I figured, well, I don't
want to poach onto that.
But there is very
interesting data there.
Yeah, I know there was a
dating service started up that
was specifically using
musical taste as a way to kind
of connect people.
But how important--
musical taste matters
more at a certain
time of life, right?
It's a more affiliative,
associative thing
at a certain time.
So in online dating, you're even
using broader things than that,
and that's still pretty
poor predictively.
So just something
like music is--
my wife actually wrote for
"Rolling Stone" for many years,
and we have pretty
different musical tastes,
and we've been
married for 15 years.
So I think it's kind of
interesting and perhaps
important in some initial
just conversational way.
But as far as-- it's not one
of these sort of underlying
themes, I would think.
It can be associated with
other lifestyle factors.
I mention the Insane
Clown Posse in the book.
There are two Juggalos that
meet and decide to get married,
they may have a broader set of
interests than just that music
or they may not.
SACHIT EGAN: Sure thing.
So one thing I appreciate
about your books
is-- a friend and I joke that
the last half of the book
is footnotes.
And I know that you like to
have your points grounded
in research, right?
So I know that maybe you
haven't researched online dating
to the effect that you
can be the expert on it.
I guess I'm curious,
you talk so much
about how likes come
from-- we don't even
analyze how we get our likes,
why we like things we do.
There's fluidity to our likes.
One day we hate
something, tomorrow it's
our favorite thing.
Does it make you
skeptical of likes?
Or does it make you
kind of encourage us
to want to think
more about our likes?
TOM VANDERBILT: Well,
it's a good question.
And what are likes?
Is an Instagram like the
same as a YouTube thumbs up,
the same as a five-star--
these are very kind of inexact
currency here that--
SACHIT EGAN: You liked
that YouTube video.
So did I. We should hang
out sometime, right?
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah, there's
so much noise in all that stuff,
right?
If you thumb up the best
kitten video you've ever seen,
is that the same as you kind
of mildly like something?
There's only one signal.
It reminds me of
something, though,
that there's a difficulty
to trying to drill too far
down into some of the stuff.
I was talking to the people at
Pandora and they, for a while,
were going to do sort
of a little A/B test
with a feature where instead
of just simply thumbing down,
you could actually describe
why you didn't like
or why you liked a song.
And when they-- the
minute they started
that up, it was
just like, this was
the favorite song at
my daughter's wedding,
this was this, this
was-- they had no way
to basically do anything
with any of that information.
So they just--
they got rid of it
and went back to-- so sometimes
a thumb up or thumb down
is really all you want.
SACHIT EGAN: I see.
Speaking of which,
one other question
we threw out in
the marketing was,
YouTube used to have a five-star
rating system for videos,
but why'd they go
away from that?
TOM VANDERBILT: I think they
felt that people-- a lot
of people were just using five
stars as an implicit thumbs up,
and there was just
not enough-- there was
a heavy skew toward five-star.
And that's something
you see, of course,
in a lot of these data sets.
And I've come to be very
suspicious of-- almost discount
entirely, except when
it's my book on Amazon,
five-star reviews
and one-star reviews,
because they each come
with their own set of--
and we all know this,
but one-star review
is someone's grinding
a very heavy axe there
about the bad night they
had at a restaurant.
And five stars is probably a
friend or a plant, a fraud.
SACHIT EGAN: I see.
TOM VANDERBILT: So 3 and
1/2 is sort of the happy--
where you find the
interesting stuff, I think.
SACHIT EGAN: That's
good to know.
I want to ask you one or two
more we go to the audience.
One of these things is
conformity versus distinction.
And you cite conformity
versus distinction
as one of the tensions that goes
a great way towards explaining
our liking, towards
accounting for our taste.
The example I thought
of right away--
conformity and
distinction-- is men's ties.
Neither of us are wearing a tie.
I remember, I don't know,
it was in high school,
and it was about the
time when I said hey,
I should probably
care about how I look.
And at the time, these sort of
thickish ties were in style,
so I bought a bunch
of thicker ties.
And by the time
I got to college,
the skinny tie was back,
thanks to "Mad Men,"
and I was a schmuck
all of a sudden.
What about these trends
of-- you talk so much
in the book about how likes
just change with trends.
Can you talk about that?
TOM VANDERBILT:
Yeah, for that part,
I talked a lot to
anthropologists,
because I think there's a huge
social learning component here
that probably has an
evolutionary story, if you
want to go there.
I always thought the word
ape was sort of ill-chosen,
because humans mimic much
more strongly than apes.
There's some great research
by Michael Tomasello that
take a glass box, and there's
something trapped inside,
and if you show-- a chimp will
show-- have the human do it,
the chimp follows it,
the chimp will sort of
figure out what
the best way to do
it is pretty quickly regardless
of what the human is doing.
The human will
continue to follow
the-- the human watching
the box will continue
to follow the demonstrator,
even when they're doing it
in an inefficient way,
because they're not sure
that there's some
sort of social norm
that they should be following.
We just implicitly
trust what other people
are doing as a signal, perhaps
going back to this time
when we lived in small
bands, and conformity was
survival in a way.
And that raises the question
of why anyone does anything
different, and that
perhaps has a larger basis
in just contemporary society of
trying to achieve distinction
through-- so it's a
very complicated thing.
But so yeah, I think a
lot of these processes
are just literally-- there's
a great story in the "New York
Times" about-- you may have
seen with the sprouts trend that
took off in China in
the last few years,
where people were putting
these sort of plastic sprouts
of vegetables or fruit
replicas in their hair.
And this article
was spending a lot
of time trying to explain why.
And the only reason they
could really come up with
is that people had seen other
people doing it, specifically
on social media, and people
on Instagram with selfie
sticks photographing them.
So someone saw it and
they decided to mimic it.
They said, that's sort of cool.
I don't see a function for
it, but I'll try it out.
SACHIT EGAN: I see.
You mentioned the
hipster effect as one.
I was very glad to hear there's
an effect that's called that.
And I could be
butchering it here,
but the obvious question,
when enough people
are putting sprouts in their
hair because it's cool,
you're part of this cool club,
what happens when everybody's
now got sprouts in their hair?
Does it change?
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah,
it almost reminds
me of sensory-specific
satiety, where
there's no reason we should
fatigue of seeing-- or even
hearing the same song.
There's not quite the
same thing as nutrition.
But if suddenly
everyone's wearing
the same shirt in this
room, biologically it
doesn't fatigue our eyes.
So there's some
other social thing
where some people need a
certain amount of distinction.
Survival of the fittest
is the one argument,
but that doesn't necessarily
explain why new things arise.
And so this is kind
of an open question,
where do innovators come from?
Where do artistic
innovators come from?
They should really be doing--
for greater social success,
you should conform to
the existing group.
And that's a much harder thing
to explain, the disconformity
than conformity.
SACHIT EGAN: I see.
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah,
but Jonathan Touboul,
this mathematician,
did a great analysis
where he sort of
said there's once
in a while, a
statistical oscillation,
where because the conformists
and the nonconformists
aren't necessarily
planning ahead
of time what
they're going to do,
they can be sort
of discoordinated,
and that the squares might start
doing what the hipsters are
doing almost by
accident or because--
and so the hipsters get annoyed.
They feel like their
thing has been co-opted.
They move on.
I use the example of shell art
from the show "Portlandia,"
where Spike the hipster,
he sees this guy doing
all the things he does--
shell art, fixed gear bikes--
and then he declares
those things to be over.
Like, why are they over?
So he can eke out another
form of distinction.
SACHIT EGAN: I see.
So it might be a
similarly U-shaped curve
that you mention that
some people have a need
to kind of be a little
removed from the norm,
and so everybody has a
particular taste for being
away from the norm.
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah.
Again, the
anthropologists will say,
this is what they call a weird
thing, Western, educated,
industrialized,
rich democracies.
There are other societies
that the conformist norms
are stronger.
But I think living in a consumer
society with endless choice,
we have a lot more
options to pick from
and different ways to
distinguish ourselves.
SACHIT EGAN: Sure thing.
One more question from me.
You can tell that I'm into
the social psych part of this.
You mentioned Freud's
famous narcissism
of small differences, the
minor variances in people
who are otherwise alike that
form the basis of feelings
of hostility between people.
And it got me
thinking, you might
have a family member or a friend
or a partner who you think
about all the major
values are in line,
background is in line,
future goals in line,
but they like some band
that you just can't stand.
And if it was a stranger
who liked that band,
you wouldn't think twice.
That difference in
like doesn't matter.
But when it's somebody
that you care for
or that you feel very akin
to, how can you like that?
That question just kind
of is a dagger at times.
Did anything in your
research or anybody you
speak to have any
suggestion as to why
those things kind of stick out?
Or is that just--
TOM VANDERBILT: Not in
kind of that social way.
I definitely remember
making mix tapes for people
and then feeling a
bit betrayed when
they reported that not 100%
of the songs were a success.
How did you misread me?
But I do think-- one
thing I thought more about
was just when you do have a
strong subculture or really
any culture-- the thing
that's fascinating
to me is there's a whole
psychology of categorization.
And the more we like something,
the more we want to categorize.
And then the more we
categorize, the more
we like the things we put
into those categories.
So if you pick any kind of--
I'm a avid cyclist, so we-- talk
about narcissism of
small differences--
we have debates about things
that, in the outside world,
would seem ridiculous.
But you go in the
cycling world, there's
sock height, what kind
of handlebar tape, carbon
or steel, or there's any
number of these distinctions
that you could argue about.
And so you could probably
take any-- punk rock
or any-- people will be
having stronger arguments
within those fields
than intra fields.
It's just because
no one else cares.
Those are the only people
that actually care.
SACHIT EGAN: I see.
Very good.
AUDIENCE: I was curious
how the internet has
played a role in our
likings and dislikings.
Has it become more
of a normalizer,
where we tend to like the
same things as everybody does?
Or has it pushed
in our extremes,
like we see in the political
systems and things like that?
TOM VANDERBILT: Yeah,
that's a great question.
I think back to
when I was younger
and I kind of discovered
this punk rock music,
let's say, in the 1980s.
And I thought I had to track
this down on a small station.
No one knew about it.
I didn't really know how
many people in the world
were actually fans of this.
So come now with
Spotify and everything,
I thought, well, if everyone
had access to everything,
then surely these kind
of hierarchical forms
of popularity would wither away.
Why would we have the pop
charts if you can get anything?
You don't only have to
listen to what the top 40
station is playing you.
But some research
that I was given
by someone who analyzes this
shows, in fact, the opposite
has happened, where hits
now sort of persevere longer
than they did before.
Songs are played
on radio longer.
In 2013, Robin Thicke's
"Blurred Lines"
was played twice as much as the
most popular song from 2003.
So I think the tail
has gotten longer,
but I wouldn't say
it's gotten fatter,
and then the spikes
have gotten higher.
So I think otherwise,
though, the internet really
amplifies existing dynamics
rather than creating entirely
new dynamics unto itself.
Yeah.
I'll stop there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I work on YouTube
recommendations.
So I would love to hear
your opinion on what's
a good set of recommendations.
Like, if you've got to
show somebody 12 videos,
should you show them, like-- if
you think they like cat videos,
should you show them a
whole bunch of cat videos?
Or should you try to
diversify them somehow?
Or maybe there's
some-- you should
show them some Total cereal
every now and then, something
that they really
don't like, just
so they can not watch it and
feel good about themselves.
So what is the optimal
video recommendation?
If you have an opinion.
TOM VANDERBILT: It's so hard.
Talking to people
here at Google,
like Amit Singhal
about Knowledge Graph,
and just how hard
search is as a problem,
trying to figure out people's
intention with their search.
I mean, taste is
just-- blows that out
of the water, the complexity.
I've talked to
people at Pandora.
If you like the band
Fun, "We Are Young,"
are you coming to that because
you were a fan of them before?
Or are you coming to that
because you're a "Glee" fan?
So the thing about
recommendations-- I always
wish there was a
little bit more,
and maybe some
services even have
this that I'm not aware of
this, but some dials or sliders,
where you can sort of tweak
your own appetite for discovery
or adventure-- hey, I'm
feeling more adventurous today.
Is there anything like that
currently on YouTube or--
AUDIENCE: No.
Currently, it's
completely passive.
It just says here's a bunch--
if you go to YouTube home page,
you just get a bunch of videos.
There's no way that you can
interact with that process.
Except for if you really
care about something,
you can click on
a video and say,
I don't like this
recommendation.
But very few people do that.
TOM VANDERBILT: And a cat
video is a much slipperier
format than music.
I mean, cat-- I guess it
is a genre, cat videos,
but you don't have genres.
Well, I may be speaking
out of turn here.
I don't know if there might
be genres within cat videos.
The cat scared by the
cucumber or something.
So hey, I want more.
Yeah, it's just-- stuff like
that seems so slippery to me.
I don't really know,
except maybe some
of these personalization, I'm
feeling more adventurous, but--
AUDIENCE: So I feel like
in the last few decades
with massive industrial
production of things,
I've heard this term come up,
institutionalized good taste,
where you get things like,
you buy clothes at Gap,
you're not going
to look too weird.
You drive a Volkswagen, you're
not going to look too weird.
Everybody has a Apple computer,
and they all look really good.
What sort of effect
has that had,
do you think, on
taste in general?
TOM VANDERBILT: It's
a great question.
I've often, like,
at Christmastime,
going to Pottery Barn or some
of these stores at the mall,
and they all seem to be playing
the same kind of tasteful retro
Christmas music.
And at some point, what would
have been rare a while ago,
suddenly just became this
almost inescapable norm.
I feel like the internet,
with Instagram in particular,
has radiated fashion
trends much more quickly.
There used to be this process
of the Parisian shows,
the stuff trickling over here,
the stuff trickling from New
York to the hinterlands.
Burberry is now selling
some of the stuff
directly from their runway show,
because there's no lagging,
where people can take an
Instagram of the runway show,
and that trend is
immediately blasted out.
So in some ways,
whatever the distinction
or the rarity of that fashion
trend has now been lost.
So I don't know.
It's a slippery thing.
There's always a reaction when
there's too much of one thing.
And I've seen some arguments
in favor of ugly fonts
or-- because there
is something where--
there's some research
with font fluency.
The more fluent the
font is, the less likely
you are to remember what
you're reading, because it just
goes down so easily.
So to really stand out in a
world of uniform good taste,
you just have to take a left.
And I'm trying to
think of-- something
like brutalism in architecture
has ridden various waves
of liking and disliking.
Reappreciation.
A building like the Sydney
Opera House in Australia.
What is the most loved
building in Australia today?
The Sydney Opera House.
What was the most hated
building in Australia in 1973?
The Sydney Opera House.
And everything changed around
the Sydney Opera House.
Sydney Opera House
changed things itself.
See?
That's where it's just this
fascinating, very fluid,
dynamic, I think, if that
answers your question,
which I don't think it does.
AUDIENCE: Movie critic
A. O. Scott was here
about a month ago, and he talked
about the role of the critic,
now that everybody
can essentially voice
their opinion on the media.
So I was curious
where you think--
what the role of other
people's opinions are
and where can
authority come from?
And what's the role of a
sort of authoritative voice
on a particular piece of media?
TOM VANDERBILT: Yes, but I,
myself, don't necessarily
subscribe to the kind of full
democratization of everything,
that we can do away
with-- because if you look
at all these
services, they've all
tried to reinstill authority
under some other guise.
And so we say the restaurant
critic is dead, but then
on Yelp, you have
the expert reviewer.
All these services now
have some delineation
between the average schmuck
and an Amazon top 500
reviewer, who may be reviewing
everything from hammers to
[INAUDIBLE].
It's a very slippery thing.
They're not necessarily
a critic in one thing.
So I feel like we may have had
this initial reaction of sort
of tearing things down
and just opening ourselves
to all the information
in the world,
but there now may be a secondary
thing happening where it's just
too much, and we need
some kind of authority
just to wade through the morass.
And you've seen some
kind of flip-flopping
between pure algorithmic
recommendation
and human curation
in this regard.
It's funny, though.
Taste is a very controversial
thing, really, I mean,
just the notion of it.
And when I was talking to
Pandora about visiting Pandora,
they said-- I'm working
on a book about taste.
They said, well, we don't
really like to use that word.
We're not trying to prescribe
anyone's taste here.
We're about discovery and
you can like what you like.
We'll point you to that.
And there is still the
uncomfortable truth
that they don't have
every song in the world.
They've made a decision
about what they're
going to play for
you within this--
we'll give you a sandbox,
but they've outlined
the edges of that sandbox.
So I think the authority
thing is still there.
But whether it's individual
critics at newspapers,
I'm not sure.
I'm less optimistic
about that perhaps.
AUDIENCE: So Veblen wrote "The
Theory of the Leisure Class,"
which is a 19th century book
where he does discuss taste
as well being a product
of social stratification.
Is there anything left
over from that theories
today or is it all consumerism
and pure consumerism?
TOM VANDERBILT:
I think there is.
I just think the stratification
is a bit less purely
hierarchical the way it
might have been before.
The 1% out there
probably has a taste.
I don't know that
it really becomes--
that we aspire to it anymore.
And I think there's
been a lot of research
into-- I use the example
of the quotative like.
This is the thing where
we say "like" a lot.
That didn't come
from wealthy people.
That came from high schoolers
in San Fernando Valley,
as the research has shown.
That's not necessarily a status
group for society as a whole,
yet that has filtered
throughout society.
So just the transmission
of those things, I think,
is not quite as top
down as it used to be.
I'm sure it's still there,
just in many different ways.
But just looking
at this room, you'd
be hard-pressed
to kind of analyze
who made more money
than other people.
I may have the most expensive
jacket on in the room.
I may make the less money.
It's a very--
AUDIENCE: I guess this
room is the 1% room.
So--
SACHIT EGAN: Thank you.
One final question, Tom.
It's a classic end of
interview question, OK?
TOM VANDERBILT: OK.
SACHIT EGAN: What surprised you
the most in preparing this book
and researching it, writing
it, talking about it?
TOM VANDERBILT: Oh god.
And I still haven't gotten
good at answering that.
I don't know.
I think just the fluidity
of a lot of the things,
and the extent to which
subconscious influences might
be acting on what we thought
were long-held or sort
of internal likes.
And just how
flexible my own likes
were when I really sort of
examined them and put them
under the microscope,
and started
to think about who I
was 10 years ago, who
I'll be 10 years from now.
But yet how strongly we
cling to those things.
They really seem like
a polestar to us.
I don't know if that's
really surprising.
I think I'll need to work
on that one some more.
I'm sorry.
SACHIT EGAN: Tom Vanderbilt's
"You May Also Like,
Taste in an Age of Endless
Choice" is now available.
Thank you, Tom, for being here.
TOM VANDERBILT: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]